dr. Jason Wang is the director of the
Center for policy outcomes and
prevention at Stanford the University
now he says the use of disinfectants
sprays helps people psychologically but
has no real benefit I think the message
spread of benzalkonium chloride probably
would cause more harm than good to the
population one of the things that we
know about this chemical is that it gets
to the skin so it could cause skin
irritations it gets to the lungs
so it was slowed down the ciliary
motions in the lungs
and they could in some cases lead to
asthma and some of the cases also show
that it could affect the eyes and so I
think it's probably more psychological
than actual benefit to the population
now if one will just use this chemical
maybe in a more targeted area where you
avoid the crowds for example in
decontaminate in a hospital room where
people could be touching the surface I
think that makes more sense than a
massive spread in in the population and
finally I would like to comment that
personal hygiene is very important so
you know teaching people to wash their
hands and and avoid touching things
touching their eyes is probably more
effective than a massive spread of over
chemical